A Google style of carefulness was being
applied by a startup whose sole job was
to explore the risky path.
>> You can end up where the process becomes
this big
>> [music]
>> and the actual product is this big. It
It'd be like if if the bolt factory
there was a thousand process people and
one guy making bolts. And one bolt a day
comes out of the factory.
Welcome to Dalton plus Michael. Today
we're going to talk about We might even
debate Oh.
>> slightly.
Process, procedure, the P-word.
Bureaucracy, meetings. And the kind of
the prompt for this one is um confusing
an organized process with an effective
process and confusing chaos with
ineffective or bad outcomes. Yeah, I
mean
I think the context here is you and I
have debated this for many years as
colleagues.
>> Would people guess which I don't know
that people
>> Yeah, what do you think? Who's the pro
process and anti-process?
>> Yes. And who's the chaos guy?
>> Yeah, who's I think they would assume
I'm the chaos guy. I think they might.
People who know me would never
>> It's a great point. You're right. I
actually have no idea if people
understand that I'm the anti-process guy
>> [laughter]
>> and that you're the pro-process guy. I
don't know if that's obvious. Beats me,
man. Tell us in the comments.
Tell us in the comments.
>> [laughter]
>> Um and so yeah, so the general debate is
Michael would be like, "Oh, we need a
structured process to do X, Y, and Z."
>> Yes. And I'm like, "Why?" Yes.
>> That sounds bad. We would end in many
different places.
>> Yeah. It depends on the case. [laughter]
There's going to be some process and
maybe no process. Yeah. But it was
always an interesting debate because it
was always a I always liked the debate
because process should always be treated
skeptically. Yeah. It should otherwise
it'll otherwise it'll Exactly.
>> take over. Someone has to be the devil's
advocate for any new process. And you
played that role.
>> [laughter]
>> Fair enough. Fair enough. So how should
people think about useful process versus
bad process? Useful process, so to take
the opposite to to argue the opposite
side that I'm usually on, useful process
is the following. Once a best practice
exists Yes.
>> you should just do the best practice.
Otherwise you're just wasting a ton of
time. Think about um automation, like uh
the Industrial Revolution, where if
there's one way to make a bolt on an
assembly line, just keep making the
bolts. Those bolts are going to be
better in every way than a bespoke
welder trying to make a bolt by hand.
And so process in its best form is just
establishing a state-of-the-art best
practice and ramping it way up and
there's no question about
how to do something properly. Well, like
process in its best form, I love that
bolt example. produces a great bolt
which is better
>> every time.
>> Yeah, it's it's perfect [laughter]
and and the process identifies uh
errors. Yes.
>> Like part of the process of making the
bolt is the camera detects, "Oh, this
bolt's bad." and it throws it off the
assembly line. So yeah, the an assembly
line is an example of fantastic process.
And a great test for whether you have a
good process is the outcome good? Yes.
And and getting
>> Yeah, and consistent. And you and you
know it it's provably good. Like you can
actually measure that it's effective.
>> Yeah. What about bad process? Bad
process is just like any classic
bureaucracy where it exists to grow
itself. It's almost like a dare I say
cancer where it's a machine that all it
wants is to have more power or more
people in the process and it becomes a
vector to basically take over everything
such that you know, someone has to weigh
in on every decision and has control
over how decisions are made. There's a
whole lot of people employed in trying
to keep the process going. It's like a
jobs program. And so you can end up
where the process
becomes this big and the actual product
is this big. It It'd be like if at the
bolt factory there was a thousand
process people and one guy making bolts.
>> And one bolt a day comes out of the
factory. [laughter] Yes.
>> That would be bad process. I think an
an interesting thing about process is
when people reach for it as a solution.
And I can say it from personal
experience
there are a couple different times where
I reach for it as a solution. Um
so one is like the same problem keeps
happening. The second is fear or
anxiety. If I'm doing something for the
first time and I'm afraid that it's not
going to work
sometimes process gives me comfort.
Well, if I made a plan like, you know,
if I'm cooking something for the first
time, that have I looked up recipes and
da da da.
Um so personal fear and anxiety, but I
also think fear and anxiety for other
people. Like I actually think process
can reduce
anxiety.
That doesn't necessarily mean the output
will be good.
>> [laughter]
>> But I do think that um a lot of process
comes from people being afraid and
anxious Yep. and wanting the comfort.
And
chaos might be comforting when the
result's good. It's rarely comforting
during
the chaos.
>> [laughter]
>> Um it's it's often especially for a
certain type of people, it's often
anxiety-inducing during the chaos. Yeah.
Um
On the flip side though what's so funny
is if you were to ask me to think back
through
the biggest innovations or things that
have triggered the biggest innovations
or change or positive things, they've
all started with chaos. They've all
started with something breaking and
having to not follow
Yeah, my
>> whatever the plan was.
>> My mental model for this is the more
something looks like producing bolts the
more process works and the more that it
looks like producing art
or a hit song
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. the less you can
be like, "Here's our Here's our
process." And then And again, if you
think about what people are mad about
with, you know, the entertainment
industry, Hollywood or the music
industry, it's process
>> Yes. seeping its way MCU, yes. Right?
Like the Avengers movie, yes. That's
like that's process screwing up art. And
so that's the continuum is how much is
this art and how much is this a bolt. I
like that cuz if I if I go back to my
new favorite term, NBA-fication
there is this kind of theory that any
output could be optimized with process.
And like
yeah, if you can make a hit movie
without process, I feel that I can make
a better movie with with great process.
>> Yeah, let's just license some some comic
book guys and
>> Brad Pitt. Let's you know, like And
that's literally the entertainment
industry these days. It's like like
NBA-fication of creating art.
>> Yes. And so I think that it's tricky
because um to your point, it's funny cuz
when you're saying art, I might say
innovation. Also this makes it kind of
hard to invent a new way of doing
things. When you need to invent a new
way of doing things, you kind of need
the freedom
to maybe do stuff that's unpopular Yep.
that is scary that may be more expensive
than people right? Like all the things
that process tried to control for.
And so I think what gets tricky is like,
okay, sometimes I need to be using my
creative brain, sometimes I need to be
using my bolt brain. How do I choose,
right? And it's like well, you know when
you're trying to do your, you know,
fundraising paperwork, I probably using
my bolt brain, right? Like
>> [laughter]
>> You need to write up your own legal docs
from first principles. But like
if I'm trying to make my customer
service go better am I innovating? I
mean you you definitely want to measure
it like it's bolts. Yeah. Like I think
for a lot of process you want to start
with measurement. I agree. But like do
you just want to hire the customer
service guy from the other company?
>> It's not a bad place to start. Tricky
though. Yeah, yeah, I understand. It's
tricky. Like I always kind of will ask a
founder
where are the top three places you want
to innovate?
Like like you probably can't innovate
across 20 zones. If you think customer
service is going to be your
differentiator, maybe you don't hire
that 20-year person.
But if it ain't
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, like, you know, where do you want
to put your innovation points? I also
think that there's something about
process as a lover of process
I love iterating process.
Like one of the things I really enjoy is
okay, the factory is producing bolts too
slow. Yeah.
How do we tweak the factory?
And I think that sometimes when I
encounter people who don't like process,
they don't engage in iterating the
process. And so it's a tricky thing cuz
like some of these things have to be
done bolty.
Yep. And if you're not tweaking it and
fixing it, so now you've got a bad
factory. You know, it's like we know a
lot of people who are like, "No meetings
ever." And then it's like and no written
specs cuz I don't want to be held in the
>> [laughter]
>> I mean this may be too in the weeds, but
I think a great example of good process
is um code reviews. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> A written spec like Well, no, no, let's
not even go to the spec part, but
basically
you know, the the default thing a
startup does is everyone can just ship
to production and then you break the
website and then you're like, "Yeah,
maybe not that." And you you have to do
a couple of layers before you can ship
to production. I might even argue just
staging. Yeah.
But any But But I think this is a you
know, this is an interesting point where
it's kind of like being too extreme on
either side scares you. Like I think
what was so fun working together is that
we could play like process dude and like
chaos dude because we knew the middle
would be in like
>> Yeah. we we would kind of get the best
of both worlds. I think that
both of us without the other one that
would have had to be a little bit more
in the middle.
I think that's
>> [laughter]
>> well said.
And and where this comes into play when
you think about it for a lot of folks
out there is innovator's dilemma
which is a lot of businesses that are
going to get
killed by AI disruptors
they're going to have to ignore all the
process people.
Right? This is you know to to recap
innovator's dilemma for everybody. It's
if a business is really successful doing
A and then this new B thing comes out
and it seems potentially disruptive.
Businesses will tend not to do B
even though they know they should
because it screws up A. Like there's too
many stakeholders that are excited about
doing A and that's the whole business is
A. So why would we blow up our own
business? It opens the door, right? It
opens the armor in the business. It's
funny because that can happen for
startups too. I was talking to a startup
in the kind of EdTech space
and you know AI is enabling to do things
that
inconceivable two years ago.
But they were saying to me like oh well
the kids wouldn't want to
they really want to read Pokemon books.
But of course we can't show them Pokemon
cuz of the copyright and I'm like
I respect Pokemon. I respect copyright.
For the record. Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> All right.
Duly noted my friend.
It's on the record.
>> my record is muddy on this topic.
>> [laughter]
>> But like
it was interesting that like a a Google
style
of carefulness
was being applied by a startup whose
sole job was to explore the risky paths.
And I think like this is a kind of a
meta point that I keep on telling
founders is like hey the the the
beautifully blazed straight like
autobahn style road the big company gets
to walk that road. You are chopping down
things and you're in the for you're
blazing the path and like you might have
to bend some rules to blaze that path
but if you're walking the autobahn path
they're going to
they're going to run you over every
time. Like you represent the risk in the
economy.
Like that is your job. You're the risk.
Embrace it
cuz when you don't embrace it you're
just lying to yourself. You still are
the risk even when you're walking the
autobahn. Yeah. [laughter]
Amen. So um
it was an interesting thing. I think I
convinced him to let the kids read
Pokemon books.
>> [laughter]
>> All right. That sounds like a good
wrap-up. Thank you Dalton.
>> Sounds good. Thanks Michael.